the world's eyes may be on glasgow next
week and the most important climate
meeting in years
but here in beijing they're holding a
rather different sort of conference
welcome to the china coal and mining
expo
on a day when the country published
underwhelming plans to lessen its core
use exhibitors here were in bullish mood
about their industry
[Music]
without the call we get the power
limited
but we all want to improve
the
environment
coal is the most polluting fossil fuel
around and china burns more of it than
the rest of the world combined
the scale of these machines the scale of
this whole exhibition is pretty surreal
it feels like a different planet from
cop26 the problem of course is that it
isn't a different planet we haven't just
come here to score a cheap point but to
show the scale of the challenge china
has built a juggernaut of economy and
it's built that economy on coal power
there are jobs energy security global
supply terms at risk as it makes a very
difficult transition
the chinese government has announced new
details about its plan to peak coal
emissions by 2025 and carbon emissions
generally by 2030
but they set no new more ambitious
targets
and they promised to reduce coal
emissions but only they said gradually
the central government can be very
powerful when it wants to be and i think
we've seen that in china on a host of
issues and so clearly it's reluctant to
reign in um coal plant building and i
think that stems from concerns about
a slowdown in economic growth
this is an industry that according to
china's promises isn't supposed to have
much of a future
for all the advanced technology it's
deeply old-fashioned in many ways
but in the short term at least they are
letting the good times roll
tom cheshire sky news beijing